existe-t-il des pactes de nom espionnage
entre la france et ses alliés
ça c'est la grosse question alors il
existe des pattes d'un espionnage ou
officieux entre alliés par exemple au
sein de l'union européenne il est
globalement accepté qu'on ne fait pas de
renseignements clandestins sur les
autres partenaires de l'union vous dire
que c'est respecter je n'irai pas jusque
là certains acteurs dont un état
récemment sortie de l'union européenne
s'était fait une spécialité d'espionner
les autres états membres de l'union
européenne
le but c'est pour chacun des états c'est
d'être sûr qu'il puisse compter sur ses
partenaires et qu'il n'y ait pas de
double jeu et puis surtout de réaffecter
ces moyens sur d'autres cibles que
l'espionnage de ses amis toutefois moi
je crois que c'est une mauvaise chose je
prends l'exemple de 2003 camp nou lé
français en tout cas les gouvernements
de jacques chirac
c'était très opportunément opposée à
l'invasion de l'irak
et bien parce que nous n'espérions pas
nos alliés nous avons découvert avec
stupeur que finalement une lettre était
signée par la quasi totalité des états
membres de l'union européenne pour
soutenir cette invasion américaine il
nous sommes retrouvés très esseulé à ce
moment
non